[Music]
hey everyone welcome we're playing the
newest infinite warfare zombies map
attack of the radioactive thing I'm
Callie I'm joined by Jake Decker how's
it going
and special guest Lee Ross who's the
associate project director director for
zombies at Infinity Ward welcome thanks
for having me
all right so tell us a little bit about
this map so this is the fourth map for
zombies on infinite warfare and it's 50s
themed this is the fourth map so we're
continuing our trip back through time
we're going backwards again as you guys
can tell we are in the black and white
land of the 1950's and along for this
ride of course our four main
protagonists have come along again all
of their playing new roles this time we
also have that awesome small kind of
awful alert Wilder who's come along for
the ride who's putting us through this
crazy terrible thing but of course he's
Willard Wyler so he's brought a
celebrity along and we have none other
than cassandra Peterson aka Elvira and
it's actually Elvira it is actually a
virus that is so cool so can you talk a
little bit about the inspiration for us
now because we've been to the 80s in the
first map in the nineties of 70s and now
to the 50s
like what where'd you get the idea
where'd you guys get the idea for moving
to the 50s well we always knew that we
were gonna be traveling through time as
we sort of went through all these
different period pieces and explore
these different films we want to keep
players on their toes it was kind of
expected when we went from the 80s to
the 90s players thought oh well they're
gonna go to the 2000s there and all of a
sudden we made a u-turn and we went back
to the 70s so the 50s was we want to
keep players on their toes what we going
back further or we're gonna go wake up
up to the future of the idol so we want
to this is a tough map so we want it we
want to keep people guessing as as to
what we're gonna do also the 50s really
when you think back to sort of the
horror movie blockbusters that
sort of encompass our world today and it
sort of started out it started out with
films like you know Dracula The Creature
from the Black Lagoon the blob things
like that warp the world we wanted to go
back and explore sort of the beginnings
of early horror cinema and I think the
50s was a great period to start that
there were some great period pieces I
mean obviously things like psycho who
sort of invented you know the idea of
what blood would look like in black and
white using chocolate syrup things like
that right you know there were things
that we wanted to explore by going back
to that period of time and I think the
50s was really a great place to say what
was horror like in the beginning sort of
the infancy of what a horror movie
experience was like and I think the
first thing that he learned was for the
50s was really monochrome right and so
we wanted to bring that experience and
then kind of you know let players most
players that's in all fairness are
probably not people who grew up in the
1950s duty right and look back oh yeah
this is so accurate to the 1950s
just like I remember exactly that's how
I remember so this is sort of also a
chance for us to give people a little
bit of you know educational history as
we go back to this period and kind of
show them what films were like back in
that time people have kind of come
become a little bit of customed to the
idea that you know the idea of summer
blockbusters which incidentally didn't
start until the 1970s so people think
that you know it's it's kind of always
been this way there's always been
horrible to zero has always been you
know five new movies out every Friday
evening you know but it's not like that
and so this this was our chance to kind
of show them what films were like way
back when mm-hmm yet like I'm a big 80s
fan so I was really drawn into zombies
in space landers the first map
so it's just cool to see like a
different time period and get back it's
hard to talk and not die that's some
color back now and that color is being
introduced by none other than Elvira
so she's the host of this episode and
now a lot of people kind of expected you
know most of the the celebrities that
we've brought in they're all playing you
know protagonists that have been thrown
into this experience well then why are
while she's been thrown into this this
experience not exactly in the same way
that our our previous cast members have
been thrown in right what she's actually
doing is she's actually hosting this
episode and that's actually what Elvira
is known for and I bring that up to
humans yeah
you mentioned the 80s and sort of
growing up watching horror films during
that time period
you know in the 80s Elvira was hanging
out on her velvet couch and she was sort
of talking about these 1950's
experiences she was talking about sort
of these b-movie experiences that we
kind of laugh at today right
these were genuinely frightening people
in that in the 1950s you know the idea
of the blob you know this this thing
rising up from your sink and then you
know ultimately dissolving and eating
you and growing and taking over your
neighborhood I think people were afraid
of these things you know right I want to
talk about them the map a little bit
actually just going off of that I ran
into radioactive waste which is not good
for you yes um I want to stay away from
the radioactive waste it is not your
project yes I want to talk a little bit
about like how do you marry that that
kam penis the kam penis of like what we
think of as a 50s horror movie with
zombies obviously have this really you
know like comedy like star-studded cast
like SNL alumni and stuff like that does
that help with the effect of kind of
revisiting 50s horror oh absolutely you
know one of the great things is you know
bringing Elvira into this mixes we've
kind of been playing a little bit off
her stick this whole experience
I mean Willard Wyler has kind of been
playing the role of Elvira and I think
that's kind of been one of the fun
things about pairing her and Paul
Reubens up as characters together in
this world is like they kind of get to
play off each other we've had this this
guy who's who's this overarching villain
who's you know really giving you guys a
hard time about this whole experience
and then now we've thrown in this this
this
person that kind of gets to say hey you
know what you're not so in charge after
all I'm gonna mix this place up a little
bit and that's why we have the color
she's restored the color she's made some
changes to this film that hopefully
helped us survive helped us escape and
then hopefully get hurt and herself out
of this location as well yeah I mean if
you go back and watch some of those 50s
movies there can't be just and watching
them themselves I mean you're right it's
kind of hard to take their dialogue
seriously at times because it really is
so campy and so over-the-top but at the
same time it really plays up to the
strength of what we're doing which is
playing up this really over-the-top
can't be experienced or for zombies I
mean right we definitely don't take
ourselves or really serious yeah I mean
if you played zombies in the space land
if you're watching this you know you
have David David Hasselhoff is the DJ
like it's very tongue-in-cheek this
whole series of zombies maps so for your
viewers that were checking me out a
moment ago I came over to the shark and
I found this new cleaver is a very
important item to have as a matter of
fact one of the things that it does is
new to zombies which is we've added the
ability to upgrade your melee so my
melee has actually been upgraded oh I
like in one hit these zombies with that
cleaver but it also has a secondary
purposes it's dealing with in this map
so I'll leave people to figure out what
it's used for at school I'm sure they do
figure those things out okay cleaver
does it stay one-hit-kill throughout the
whole thing it stays one-hit-kill for
quite some time actually okay and that
is that that's a great questions I think
that's the sort of the thing on people's
minds the minute they see a new weapon
especially when they have a weapon is
this can you see just how long can use
this thing for so yeah that's a really
good question
it'll last you for quite a while I would
say probably
around 5 or 7 it'll start to turn into
meeting two two swipes or so to take
guys down but where it's really asked
tell is you know we introduced special
waves between you know round four and
seven somewhere around there you're
gonna see somebody pop up that's not
just a normal zombie fare in this
particular map we've introduced a new
enemy type called the crog's and the
clouds are sort of just like they sound
there's sort of a hybrid of like a frog
and a crab they are heavily armored and
Phineas creatures that are very very
fast and unfortunately we've become very
accustomed to shooting things facing
them well these guys are armored in the
front and so if you want to lay waste to
them you're gonna need to shoot them in
their backs now in zombies the most
valuable thing that you can find is ammo
it's it is it's gold it's worth its
weight in gold and so you don't want to
waste your ammo and so when you're
fighting the crog's if you're just
dropping bullets into their chest you're
just wasting your ammo but with this
meat cleaver you can actually do some
dodge mechanic you know move to the left
move to the right straight out of the
way and then just one tap to their back
and they're dead and so it can be very
very useful
now we've structured this map the way
that we've built this is that you notice
that I'm in a very open area and here
come the croc that we were just talking
about so you'll notice that when they
swipe and they miss they get stuck their
closet will get stuck in the ground you
know give you sort of a moment to sweep
behind them and then and then get your
you're attacking on them now when they
do get stuck you have that moment to
strike you can either shoot them or you
can you can melee them but if you'll
notice they leave these little pools of
green acid behind now those pools of
acid are absolutely deadly to you so you
have to be careful how you use that man
so I know I'm coming over here pitch and
use this melee it's really powerful very
careful that you don't end up sliding or
sore or running into one of those those
those puddles because they are very very
different
oh god these guys are really hard - yeah
these guys are much much tougher and
these are considered a special waves
they are always a continuous evolution
of things that we've introduced in the
past gameplay mechanics we've introduced
in the past so in zombies is based on
what we talked about a little bit
earlier you know we have those killer
clowns that would right run over to you
and explode now God now one of the
things about the clowns is that yeah
they were really deadly because they
brought over to you and explode right
but they weren't an obstacle because
once they detonate it they were gone
right yeah so these guys become an
obstacle they actually can lock you into
a location very very similar to the
creatures that we introduced in braving
the redwoods in the Sasquatch's because
the Sasquatch didn't explode they would
sort of corner you and be really easy to
get overwhelmed and that was kind of the
idea with you guys is we wanted to
introduce somebody that had an evolution
of all those mechanics mm-hmm we want to
have the speed and the danger they're
very deadly and they get their their
claws into you right but then also if
you just try to sit in a corner and just
lay waste into them you can actually
paint yourself into a corner of depth
yourself because that acid then prevents
you from being able to get out safely so
it is a little bit of a double-edged
sword also because of the way that we
have you fighting them where we have
this Dodge mechanic built in you're
going to want to fight them in open
areas these are not enemies you're gonna
want to fight an enclosed space because
if you cut off your route by dropping
their acidic pools on the ground you're
you're you're stuck right and so you
really have to be careful where you're
fighting and exactly how you're fighting
and so there's a bit of strategy
involved right and is that part of the
map design then is is creating kind of
those bottlenecks and then open areas
that you're trying to get to yes
absolutely
hardly level designer Britney Maxie you
know part of the part of the exercise
that she goes for when she builds these
passes she really wants to think about
how she wants the experiences to play
you know what did what is she looking
for
looking for vertical gameplay and this
experience is she looking to have wide
open lanes or tight spaces and so the
way that she constructs these maps is
she goes through and actually build one
play space at a time so we'll play
through that play space and say did this
meet your goal are we playing in the
play style that you were trying to meet
and if we've gotten there then we start
to figure out where this next location
builds off of you and how it's going to
play how it enhances just into the next
area so yeah we kind of build these
pieces very modular Lee and then
assemble them together and then kind of
smooth it out as we go through deeper
and deeper game play testing but yeah
it's all about how we want to get the
the spaces to play and then also as
we're introducing these new entity types
we have to figure out what's going to be
the most fun way to interact with that
that crop you know gonna be fun to just
fight him in an enclosed space those are
also gonna feel fun to sort of pounce
smart him to get him to attack me and
then dodge out of the way so that I can
strike him from behind so there's
because there's a little bit of that
stuff too mm-hmm now I know I know I've
talked about the crog's and sort of how
badass they are and they're really
awesome and all that stuff but I wanted
to talk about this croc this just way
out here yeah we shake was gonna ask
about this by the beach
so this croc isn't just out here for
decoration although she is she's
actually really big and she actually has
some gameplay elements so those crog's
that were getting logged in are actually
being spawned from her back so John has
these holes in her back where she can
catapult them out and send them into the
gameplay space now if you're really
really good you can actually follow her
eggs as they're shot in the air and you
can shoot them in the air before they
ever hit the ground oh so there's a
little bit of strategy there however
they move pretty quick and their
trajectory is pretty tough to to manage
but if you can get to it you can take
those eggs out before they get to the
ground then you're like if you don't
think you'll be able to make it to an
open area or if you just want to avoid
having to deal with a bunch of those
guys start taking them out before they
ever
the light effects this is definitely one
of the more open zombie yeah yeah we
wanted this space to feel I mean if
you're gonna be at a beach it's really
hard to turn a beach into a tight
enclosed space
not to mention the maps that we're
coming from from our most recent
endeavors we built some really tight
enclosed spaces you know and we brought
people to New York City in Shaolin
shuffle although it's New York City it's
the Big Apple it really was a really
tightly confined location we were
bringing you into the confines of the
subway mm-hmm you know we were really
choking you in some of the tunnels but
this map we wanted some we want to give
anything back out into these spaces that
kind of feel a little bit more open you
know one of the other things too is that
all of our maps thus far have taken
place at night this is the first time
that we've actually brought players into
the daylight so we've sort of taken away
our own piece of comfort which is using
the dark to scare people we also wanted
to touch on the fact that the daylight
could be just as scary it doesn't need
to be you know stars in the skies and
the moon in the sky for us to be
terrified because if I saw that thing at
2 o'clock in the afternoon or at 9 p.m.
it wouldn't matter that probably running
through the dulls all right is she gonna
do something in a second I feel like
he's gonna show she'll definitely do her
posturing and she's always working on
this shoreline there's nothing that we
can do to her just yet but there is
definitely going to be a point in time
in which we're going to want to be doing
things to her
because we're gonna want to clean up our
Beach ak8 so Nova Beach so there any
other troubles you guys may have had or
maybe more open zombie map that's also
in the daylight oh it's always a
challenge I mean anytime you go away
from the tried-and-true game play you're
you're setting yourself up for
challenges but we like that we like the
things that make us feel like and I'm
down sorry guys I liked it we like the
things that make us feel like it's not
going to be the thing that people expect
us to do we want to do the thing that
people aren't expecting us to do right
and so taking on a location like an open
Beach and trying to figure out how to
make this play like a traditional
zombies experience this is a challenge
we want to take on because
if we can do this successfully this is
something that we can then use again in
the future we can get back to this again
in the future and figure out ways to
reenact this this idea this formula into
the existing system all right guys I
don't know oh don't worry we're gonna
see if we can get back and of course our
trusty afterlife arcade is back in the
house so nice so if you happen to die
you can always come back in earn
yourself some coins and we are out so
we'll come pool come back in we'll come
back in if you're just joining us we're
playing the newest zombies map for
infinite warfare it's called
attack of the radioactive thing it's 50
themed and we'll do better this time we
got this it's a learning process
talking play it's it's always easy to
sit down and get into the zone but when
you actually have to sit down and focus
and have a conversation about something
very specific but also achieve a goal in
the game at the same time it's kind of
like that old thing of rub your tummy
and pat your head at the same time and
you are really good especially in
zombies too because every little
movement can be worse yeah so we talked
about they talked about quite a bit but
there's a couple of other things I want
to touch on there's a couple other
things that we did that while they're
not they're not game changing amazingly
crazy things one of the things that you
see at the beginning here this little
splash screen this is something new that
we were doing attack of the radio thing
we wanted to kind of make it feel like
you work in a 50s movie so there's all
this even this artificial noise that we
have going on on the screen it's the way
that the audio is processed when that
music comes out and displays that
iconography
we really wanted players to kind of feel
like this was that that that classic
returned back to the period not just not
just from the outfits that the
characters are wearing or the fact that
they say daddy Oh every other word they
do but we also like I said we wanted it
to feel like that tradition would be
like we've made the other movies feel
like movies we wanted this one to feel
like that too and there's a lot of
little touches like the comic book strip
that you get at the bottom from
collecting
your iconography all the little things
that we do to sort of spruce up the
visuals and make the adjustments and
changes that make each episode feel
unique and their own mm-hmm and so like
in zombies and Spacely and a lot of that
was soundtrack is there a 50s soundtrack
to this or is it mostly in the sound
design yes there is a 50 soundtrack much
like zombies in space land and actually
showers shuffle for that part that part
well we have we have jukeboxes which are
located in and around this mouth that
once the power is activated which I was
going to go turn on the power when I was
down on the beach you can actually get
the power back on and you get those
jukeboxes playing no there is a good
chance you're getting here yeah you're
gonna hear some some classic 50 stuff
that you might recognize it starts out
in the clips you so definitely keep your
ear open to the stuff that you're gonna
hear and then because we talked about
music I know people are gonna are gonna
want to know but is there a secret song
is there a secret song can we make a
secret song for this map absolutely and
it is a really cool secret song that was
put together by a couple of the guys at
our studio Chris Eggert and Nakia Harris
shout-out to you guys for all the
awesome writing and then of course Chris
Piero and Nico Allen who they helped
perform guitar and vocals for it so cool
you guys look forward to finding that
song and getting a chance to hear it and
as always once you find the secret song
you can turn it into your front-end
music if you want to hear it in the
front end all the time so you get your
front end music you box going on there
oh yeah there is definitely 50s tracks
sprinkled all throughout this is about
you know that's I think that's one of
the things that's that's sort of become
something that we've been I guess known
for is that we we really love to put
music into our entries right and that
month that way hearken back all the way
to the fact that some of the guys that
are working on this team go back as far
as you know when we were never soft and
we're working on Tony Hawk a guitar hero
and both of those games I mean obviously
have a very very big music
influence right that's definitely
something that we help bring into this
franchise as well as we definitely want
it to
there's something about a hero
soundtrack there's something about
having that awesome music playing in the
background that gets to you you know
your blood pumping you're feeling really
good and all of a sudden you're
performing better you just you're
feeling like a like a superstar mm-hmm
there's just something about it that we
really we really enjoy I always had a
zombie playlist whenever I played this
awesome yeah chance to meet them when we
worked on guitar during Metallica really
and really such cool guys such cool area
natives - I think right they are
actually we came up here we did Guitar
Hero Metallica and they did a private
concert just for never oh my god yeah I
pretty much just sat in the front row is
ruled yeah fangirl fur amazing yeah we
got lots of great music in this one
there's a lot of lots of new stuff a lot
of little tweaks that we've done to this
map that that we wanted to do in the
past just time and constraints for
testing and all those things we we
always want about great content but
there's a new perk in this map as an
example okay
yo perks are probably the thing that can
be the game changer of the map the most
great tough or you know you pick up
something that like bang Bang's that can
double your rate of fire things like
that those could be game changer
experiences well we've introduced a new
perk and I'll try and make our way over
to it just a bit so we can actually see
it in the flesh but this new merc is
called change choose and the idea behind
this is that it actually has a sort of
an evolving personality so to speak so
when you first pick up change juice when
you get headshots it's actually gonna
have an elemental effect on zombies it
has a chance of an elemental effect so
let's say I hit this guy while I have
changed shoes in the head his head
explodes you can actually have an
electric electric
effect that stuns all the zombies in the
area that are standing next thing oh so
I could actually freeze and stun all the
zombies in that space for a short
duration which is obviously very very
very useful now we have this we have
this point in time when you're playing
the game where if you get hit and you
take too much damage we have what we
call death's door it's when your
character sort of breathing heavy the
screens blood-red or the one we're
seeing over here when I've got called
out Jake so when you're in that state
with change choose that actually can
cause your elemental state to shift so
you could go from having an electrical
elemental state to say having a fire
elemental state and so change twos can
strategically be used to alternate the
type of effect that you're using to
attack the zombies just by either taking
damage we're dealing damage mm-hmm so
it's a pretty interesting type of perk
to introduce into the map and that per
connection you found on the Main Street
area over by that market that we were
I'm gonna hit the wheel again and just
in case people haven't seen it in the
bottom left of my screen you'll notice I
have Willard's down to use the magic
wheel 15 times nice we have introduced
the multiplayer bounties in zombies um
they have been released with our most
recent title update they do not I repeat
they do not require the DLC content
really
these are bounties that are added free
of charge this is the same kind of
behavior that we've added all throughout
and you want to be careful guys about
the crog's in here this is the kind of
behavior we've introduced introduce all
throughout infinite warfare with zombies
which is we want to give the community
free content so we add new fate and
fortune cards we add new weapons that
are released in MTX they get added into
the existing maps and we also build them
into the maps that are in becoming
future releases so we're always thinking
about what we can get it into your hands
that's not just DLC content that we're
trying to sell you but it's also content
deck and it can mix up it can alter the
previous experiences that you've had in
Call of Duty so let's say for instance
you know you really love playing zombies
in space line with your dad for instance
yeah he's like oh I just want to go play
with my dad's arms in space land but
there's all these new content that's
come out those all these new fate and
fortune cards well we want you to still
enjoy that stuff so as an example we've
introduced a couple of a couple of
interesting new ones and I'll show you
guys a couple mm-hmm so let's go into my
fate cards and fate cards are awesome
because these are just unlocked by
progression so right as you progress you
go through and you unlock is like a
stimulus card we just released this and
I believe this unlocks at level 60 I
couldn't be mistaken by that we're
shooting a zombie releases a hailing
area effect for your your allies this
card you can use as many times as you
want you never lose access to these
cards now your fortune cards these are
acquired you earn by gambling sort of
sort of slow you you spend your keys you
can earn these cards so we we always are
adding to this list now these
unfortunately if you use them they're
exhausted you have to have sort of the
luck of the draw and
earn another one now I talked about
introducing that that crog enemy type so
we introduced this evade card now this
card actually adds the dodging technique
that you see an MP where you can dodge
to the right or to the left to avoid any
gunfire
now we're not necessarily having to deal
with enemy gunfire here in zombies but
at that's at that same time we now have
introduced a enemy type that has a
charging attack that you can now sort of
play mole with so you got your little
you know you a little red cape do I come
come in charge guy a little guys are
tough I am so so Satan fortune cards I
wanted to bring those up cause like I
said right that's content again that
gets released with this content but it's
free of charge this is not something
that you have to have the season pass
for it's dropped into your infinite
warfare content free of charge and it's
retroactive like you get to kind of
incorporate your acting and use to all
of the previous content that's really
cool
oh I do want to ask why
crab frogs why crab frogs so when we're
first exploring where we were going to
sort of take the player we knew we
wanted to do this beach area we knew we
wanted to get the players out into the
beach area so we started to figure out
what's sort of the and yes we got very
science-y on this and what was sort of
the the stuff that we would see living
in water and then there's the common
things than you would expect you know
you'd expect there to be a shark right
everyone right there's gonna be a shark
or a crocodile or something like that
that's that's gonna be dangerous but we
wanted to we wanted to invent something
that could be dangerous we wanted to
sort of come up with our own blob or
things like that that could that could
be tear sort of terror in our own pocket
right and I think it was Britney maxi
our level designer actually she she
brought up this picture of this frog and
when it has its babies it actually
carries its babies in sort of the nest
on its back
uh-huh and we were all so weirded out by
this frog looking at this picture going
this is like the most uncomfortable
thing to look at just it's it's it's
just so weird you make a zombies map
based around and you know wouldn't we
send it to our concept team oh we
started to do some
some exploration around what that thing
could look like and how we can make it
feel dangerous and so we slowly started
to build upon that concept of that
that's sort of that frog and before we
knew it we said you know what it's got
to have the pincers it's got to be
really big and we want it to be armored
and we want to have more than one
version of it now I've shown you two we
saw the giant krahgg boss and we saw the
miniature Crocs but there's one more
that we haven't had a chance to see and
that's my dog brute
now we introduced the brute in Spaceland
he's a giant Sphinx lamb mascot he takes
his helmet off heat beams lasers all
that do you gnarlie he's gnarly right
well we have an evolved version of him
so to speak who is like the frogs
he's armored he's much bigger than the
other frogs and he has a couple of extra
capabilities that those other crog's
don't have so as an example one of the
things that he can do is he can actually
burrow under the ground so he has like
one of those little lights like
Anglophone have that sort of hanging off
the front of him so you can see that
little angular light as he swims under
the ground so you have a tell us to
where he is look that light also has a
secondary purpose he can actually flash
bank you know many lash bands you it
stuns you it makes it so that you can't
run you can't see where you're going and
all of a sudden you're overwhelmed
you've got zombies running up on you
you've got crog's coming up on you and a
purple of course that krahgg group he
gets to burrow and zoom up right next to
you appear and he's instantly in your
face now we really enjoy the stuff we
introduced in Raven the redwoods with
the jump scares that we introduced with
the slasher yeah the slasher you'd go
into raid mode and all of a sudden he
would appear great well that's what the
croc brute gets us is that all of a
sudden you can be there and then boom
this guy just pops out of the ground and
he's not on your base instantaneously
and so we wanted to bring the jump
scares back in so three different types
of that frog krahgg crab monster was
evolved from that one picture that we
hope we all better look at one picture
of a real life just a weird yes man I
think honestly anything that can invoke
so much emotion out of somebody just by
looking at it it's something we have to
explore we have to go why are we feeling
so much energy you know towards the same
what is it that making us feel this way
and
how can we expand upon that how can we
push that even further and everyone that
we've sort of focused tested and shown
the crog's and said hey is this
something that feels frightening they're
really pretty much says yeah they
wouldn't want to run into it in a dark
alley definitely not definitely not
think I had a run-in with one of those
brutes earlier this morning I was a kid
man well yeah he's he's pre armored and
he's also he doesn't have the same
susceptibility that the the craw the
smaller frogs have which is you're not
gonna see him getting his claws stuck in
the ground very often so he's much he's
much smarter and he's also more like the
brute in that he's he takes a page out
of those classic 89 years its horror
I guess monsters is that you're gonna
kind of see him really like lumber
towards you and then all of a sudden out
of nowhere he's gonna appear next to you
and it's because he's doing that burrow
thing it's sort of like how did Jason
Voorhees walk and get to the same place
that I got to and I just ran at top
speed yeah so that's that's kind of what
the the croc routes are gonna bring to
the table and also angler fish are
probably the most frightening animal
they're just horrible looking fish I
think they're horrible I hate I hate to
be prejudiced against angler fish salt
angler fish out there I mean they really
aren't their teeth are just so
frightening looking it's just like you
don't even want to get your finger near
their mouth it just looks like they're
just gonna gnaw your your finger right
off oh yeah it it's it's one of those
things where we we knew it was an
opportunity to do something really
interesting with those guys mm-hmm plus
okay what's the name frog is this so
ridiculous that we had to do we look at
we literally sat in a design meeting man
one of our designers Matt Mason say good
krahgg would be really cool we just all
just turn and look at each other was
like ain't that's the name right there
with all of it
oh my gosh so one of the things I do
want to point out over here while I'm in
this this power area is uh here's our
trusty power switch but notice it's got
a message that the handle is missing so
we took a page out of our trip to Raven
the Redwoods which only had a single
power switch you found that single power
picture actually there's the power and
the entire facility that is exactly what
we're doing here and in fact the
radioactive things so there is just the
single power switch however it's not as
simple as finding and flipping the
switch so now you actually have to find
it reconstruct it and then flip that
switch and then you're back in business
alright so we had it just a little bit
of extra layer there for you guys
switches on each right switches on the
beach now one of the things I really
hope people picked up on this if they
didn't I'm gonna I'm gonna be a spoiler
and I'm gonna give it away anyway
but one of the things that we did is
right next to this you'll notice on the
beach there's a hand and this is the
very same hand in the nightmare summer
poster that's holding the power switch
on the beach well we wanted to recreate
the nightmare summer poster in game in
attack of the radio after thing so when
you go and pick up that that power
switch take a look at that layout guys
we it's a special attention to get that
to pay some homage to Willard Wilders
nightmare summer film so cool oh my gosh
first I wasn't sure if that was you Jake
and then I saw you slide yeah yeah
that's one of the things that Andres
character does in this map is that he
has he's a soldier and we have soldiers
on these he really throws a wrench in
the mix because you're not sure it is a
friendly or he's a threat and so you're
just kind of firing away it's like oh
wait a second that's my buddy over yeah
sorry I didn't mean to shoot it it's
incessantly but double checking I check
with bullets first yeah so we did talk
about Elvira
yeah and how she kind of plays the role
in this and we did touch on the fact
that she does restore the color so
that's how we're back in this full
cinema color mode here that she's
brought into our black and white world
but there's also things that she's gonna
talk to the player about about how we
can get her a little bit more involved
in the mix and what I mean by that is
typically when we have the celebrities
in the map we love to get them involved
in our combat and Elvira is gonna be no
different she's somebody that we want to
get involved in combat we want to get
her running around and laying waste to
these enemies so by all means there is
definitely a way to find Elvira and get
her to be active within this map so keep
your eyes peeled on ways to get her out
into the mix and help you guys take down
Willard and all of these massive frogs
Oh what about Easter eggs so Alvira
obviously is a little bit of a nod to
the era what else can you tell us about
maybe some hints so we know where to
look
oh yeah so there's Easter eggs I mean
there's there's homages and sort of nods
to these films that help define the era
things that we we felt that we wanted to
take sort of a page out of their book so
to speak that stuff you can find sort of
all over all over the place whether it's
in our our our art design or a level
layout or even the weapons that we've
created for this map there's definitely
homage to a lot of things like that
mm-hm let's talk about the weapons well
well chief initially I'm just gonna say
as far as the Easter eggs themselves we
always build them in a couple of
different capacities
first and foremost yes there's going to
be a story-driven Easter Egg that's
going to help further the quest and kind
of help us peel back this this orange
and figure out what's under these layers
there's gonna be the smaller things
there's gonna be the things like finding
the secret song or unlocking a camel or
things like that so there's oh there's
gonna be tons of little things sprinkled
throughout this entire experience I'm
gonna pick up our max I got the teddy
bear sorry hmm is this the super weapon
or the it is wonder what you have the
mad and it's gonna start off in pistol
form which is actually pretty effective
yeah it has a very powerful push effect
so you'll kind of see it throw zombies
around quite a bit but much like the
other weapons that I talked about
earlier so we talked about the cleaver
we kind of have things in this map that
they they kind of dual purpose I want to
say like yeah they're a weapon but
they're also a tool in a sense as well
so keep keep an eye on being able to
utilize things in more ways than just
one mm-hmm that will definitely open
some door for you guys as far as being
able to crack some of the deeper Easter
eggs
we had Easter eggs all all all the way
we have some we have some very vocal
fans out there that want really hard
stuff we have guys that just want you
know tip of the iceberg sort of stuff
we've got all that kind of stuff that
you guys it's all mixed and spread
throughout this map we're always looking
to try and spread the wealth as much as
we possibly can and attack of the
reactive thing is no different there's
gonna be the stuff that's gonna be
really easy stuff that people can get to
right away you know simple things like
if you just want to just high around run
around and shoot zombies you can you can
do that we have that built in but if you
want to do things like find the power
get the traps working and you know build
some of the new traps and things like
that then you're gonna have gonna have
to work a little bit harder you gonna
have to dig a little bit so turn with
that hand I was talking about there it
is grab that power handle will get the
power turned back on in this place now
once we have that we'll be able to
interact with them some of the other
cool things we talked about like change
choose which is hanging out right here I
want to check that out also I'm down
because I wasn't paying attention I was
listening to you and the Masami came up
behind me we can get over to the power
switch here
should've been playing that card all
along
I see another cards
I'm gonna play some basketball in your
cage I'm gonna be oh I got I got a point
so I'm gonna restore the power
so I'll get this whole place jumping and
driving again cool nice so I did touch
on the fact that this is gonna further
our storyline just a little bit here
we're gonna tell a little bit more about
Lillard Wyler and why he thought I'll
fire into this mix and obviously why he
shows an attack of the radioactive thing
as a film to pull us into mm-hmm I'm
back there'll be quite a bit of
information that we're gonna we're gonna
reveal here so there's a lot of a lot of
back story elements that players can
find in this map that tell a little bit
of story about Willard a little bit more
about Elvira but then also we want to
talk a little bit more about the
protagonists why are they here what is
this whole thing all about why are we in
these films is there a way out of these
films why is well they're doing this
thing
mm-hm doesn't seem like a very nice guy
but maybe you know he is maybe is it
will soon find out doesn't seem that
nice to me for sure I mean I only have a
pistol and not come prepared here well
I'm royally screwed don't forget
grenades restock every round so feel
free to let those babies fly
they're great for driving some quick
cash and clearing out some horns when
you get surrounded
yeah that's our big frog boss she
doesn't like us playing around in her
her area here like what are you guys
doing over there I'll take her where is
she like nowhere I got this guy's I just
hang back enjoy the 50s so it's really
about what what is the story that we're
trying to tell so in this particular
episode what I want to do is I kind of
want to expand upon the capabilities of
the characters and then also sort of do
a bit of a recap as to you know why were
they chosen to be this particular
protagonist in the 80s for instance why
was Poindexter chosen to be the nerd for
instance or in this episode why is he a
scientist um we're gonna talk about that
a little bit in some of the the items
that you can find within this map that
reveal a little bit more of the
backstory so keep an eye out on
information you can find from Willard
Wyler he'll be spilling the beans so to
speak a little bit in this map about
what's going on with these protagonist
what was going on with them in the
previous maps and maybe possibly what is
going on with them you need the next
[Music]
so it's like we're doing much better
this time around I will say where I am
standing with the guy who's jumping
around now this is the tough if you have
2000 or 2500 you're gonna want to buy
that that will double your health yep
we're getting to that we're getting to
that point where we're probably gonna
need to get a little bit deeper here get
a little
and it won't be long until we start to
see that that crog Brut it's right
around scene 10 they can start to pop it
out I played about 10 games last night
with some some of the community and I
would say 90% of those games the minute
we got that frog root the game ended
really yeah it becomes it becomes a
panic moment for a lot of people where
it's just like I don't know what to do
panic I'm spamming buttons I'm down and
then it's sort of a domino effect after
that one person goes down next person
goes down next person goes down and
before you know it everyone's in the
afterlife arcade and blurred glass games
what is what's the highest wave you've
made it to on this I mean I guess for
for a retail kit I don't know I think
last night I want to say one of the
group's I was playing with I think we
got to around 25 dang that's definitely
not my highest seen count or any of the
zombie maps but that's I think that's
what I have logs so far for this map but
when we're playing it at our office we
kind of have all these debug teeth that
we tend to use quite a bit so we're
going to plan yeah we're playing we're
playing til infinity and beyond if you
kind of have to though right yeah the
game doesn't use you as someone will do
it you pretty much ask you however we've
got people in our QA team that are so
insanely good that it you watch them
playing it's like you think they're in
god mode jeez you're like yeah this guy
hasn't been hit and he's on round 90 oh
wait please
yeah okay I know why because he's your
second
or her because yeah the girls and the
gals they're equally amazing do it did
you know the highest wave you've
probably earth seen you've probably made
it to all of Jenna in all of zombies
maybe not all in or justic with infinite
workers oh let's see highest I probably
say somewhere around the 70s geez my
highest and that's what a really killer
a steam that knows exactly what to do
how to kite ever and everybody's yeah
everybody's working together it's hard
to do that in a match where people are
sort of one Manning it or it's like
everyone's like well I'm gonna go get my
perks and I'm gonna get my gun and do
this when you're when you're sort of
strategizing it's like okay one person's
gonna go find all the parts another
person's gonna kite another person's
gonna work on filling up the ATM with
cash when you have when you're sort of
strategizing like that it starts to get
really easy actually especially when you
consider the fact that there's a lot we
do a lot of things in infinite warfare
zombies where we've built a lot of
things that can actually aid the other
players so a lot of the traps that we
have I can I can put a trap down that
will allow me there at the krahgg route
and he's running right after us and I'm
down soon guys as soon as I look away
but yeah there's a lot of there's a lot
of systems that we have in place that
actually complement helping other
players so it could be a fake fortune
card it could be a trap it could be a
buildable there are a lot of different
things that that can actually
help each other I could be a TM system
where I'm depositing cash it's so funny
I saw him to my left run past me he was
chasing you not me and then I went to
turn to my left to attack him and
somebody killed me from behind which was
awesome great timing
I don't know if you can get to but if
you can get out of this area and just
run we can probably come back if you can
kite out of the area we can probably
make it back no didn't do it yeah see
how are we doing on time here one more
one more
yeah I told you the moment he comes out
it's game changer because he's he's so
aggressive and he's so powerful and like
I said it's the domino effect that once
he downs one player he immediately sets
his targets on another player that's it
you're in trouble he's out for blood
what's the best way to deal with him
just try to run a distraction get behind
him well one strategy that I really like
I don't know if I should tell people
this one is I like to use I like to use
explosive weapons and we actually have
some explosive weapons in ancient places
in this map one at the beach I saw there
is and that's the one I was going to
recommend if you get an explosive weapon
that you get bang Bang's you can
actually and bomb Stoppers you can
actually just nuke the floor as you
backup with the explosive weapons and
they cause flash damage and so you can
do quite a bit of damage to the crog's
and the krahgg brute just by putting
bullets into the ground so you don't
even need to be super accurate and then
because they're so fast once they run
past you can just quick turn around put
a couple of shots in the ground and then
just keep moving so it's a strategy that
allows you to just keep being mobile the
entire time they're not a zombie that
you
type that you want to turn around and
try and hold your ground with because
they're just gonna get on top of you
really fast and I know we've kind of
cheated people by teaching them in space
lands yeah just turn around and face the
zombies and shoot the clowns there's no
big deal they just explode well as we've
sort of slowly evolved this special
zombie type through each episode we've
learned that with each strategy you guys
learn we introduce a new one new
countermeasures so keeps it fresh
exactly as soon as you guys think you
figured it out here's a new one for you
guys just because we love you guys yeah
the 50s has been a really interesting
time period to explore one of the things
that I had a really great time with as
far as story exploration for this
episode is the fact that I don't have
players of Nerdist notice this yet but
you cannot curse in this episode there's
no there's no cursing dialogue at all
and one of the things that's cool about
that is our our protagonist actually
recognized this and they start to
realize that they can't curse and they
try and they're like oh fudge and
fiddlesticks
and they're really frustrated by the
fact that they can't actually have any
expletives in this map because it's the
50s it's it's Leave It to Beaver or you
know it's exactly and so we have quite a
bit of fun going through this experience
while they're trying to be their typical
Maudie cursing selves and going through
their frustration of realizing why they
can't actually pronounce any of these
expletives and why they get changed into
famous sugary sweet family-friendly
words exactly so that actually was one
of the things that I think when we first
started talking about doing the 50s from
our comedic standpoint I think got me
most excited was being able to sort of
play up the idea that these are people
from today taking them back to the 50s
where everything was sort of sterilized
day you know exactly finish no and I
wanted them to sort of stick out like a
sore thumb and they definitely they
definitely have that feeling when they
first spawn and you get a bit of their
dialogue where they're like hey what's
going on
here why can't I say these things
anymore
exactly exactly and we talked a bit more
about how they have sort of picked up a
little bit of the personas that they've
played throughout all these episodes so
I mean you can imagine you know sort of
being injected into the persona of
somebody else and then becoming yourself
but still kind of holding on to some of
that knowledge from the previous
experience of that other person
well imagine doing this through four or
five or six or ten films were you know
in one of them you're a scientist and
then the next one you're you're a
civilian and then the next one you're a
soldier and then by the end of it it's
like wait a second I kind of remember
some of that soldier stuff and that
scientific equation stuff I don't know
so they're kind of trying to pull onto
themselves but at the same time they're
picking up all this new info don't want
to get lost in these films
[Music]
absolutely so we have to keep it we have
to definitely pay very close attention
to our dialogue trees we have to pay
very close attention to not only
dialogue trees but also the the
conversations that players have had
amongst themselves so as players are
conversating in Spaceland about
something when they go into rave we want
to be able to have them reference back
to that conversation and they have to
remember who said what and we want to
make sure that the right person is
referencing hey I remember what I said
about the red balloon shoot the red
balloon we want to make sure that all of
that stuff all ties in cohesively so
when somebody on YouTube I'm sure will
do it at some point we'll go back and
cohesively tie all the story bits
together it will all mix and match
together and they'll go Wow infinity war
to actually paid attention they knew
what they were doing always
always always that almost almost got
enough open this next area just curious
about how long does it take to develop a
zombies map like this like from
inception all the way to completion well
that's kind of a tricky question I'm
gonna give you a two-part answer to it
when we're doing it from the ground up
when we're building the very first map
so zombies in space might as an example
it takes quite a bit more time than it
does to take to make one of these Maps
because there are systems that we have
to build from the ground up so as an
example the fate and fortune part system
is not something that we need to create
every single time we create in one of
the maps we introduce new content pieces
to it we might evolve some of the the
leveling system to things like that but
we don't have to build and manufacture
the system from the ground up so we
iterate in some places and evolve in
some places and then we build from the
ground up in other places so for our
zombie types when we introduce somebody
like the crog's for instance those we
have to animate from the ground up we
have to you know build new models all of
those types of things new weaponry all
of those things same idea so it the
iteration process tends to be a little
bit faster but we push ourselves pretty
hard we we typically spend about three
and a half months or so on each of the
the DLC packs and in that span of time
that's building the map that's focused
testing and Quality Assurance testing
that map very very thoroughly and then
that's also going through rapid amounts
of iteration to make sure the map is
playing the way that we want it to that
the overall end goal is what we want it
to be so yeah it's a it's a very very
tight process even though three months
sounds like a lot of time to make it
actually is not a really long but this
is a this is a team with a tremendous
amount of development experience we've
been working together for a long time we
know we know our ins and outs and we've
worked tremendously well together and
because we do that it allows us to
iterate very very quickly so I have a
tremendous amount of trust in my design
team as an example when the design team
sits down and wants to start figuring
out what the Easter eggs are going to be
or what types of things they'd like to
be 1/8 you know they're they're kind of
coming to me saying hey so what do you
think about you know maybe if we we
handle an Easter egg this way
I put the onus on them to figure out
well why do you want it to be this way
what's gonna make it fun and I let them
figure that that stuff out and then they
come back and say okay here's the thing
that I wanted to do what do you think
and as a team we review that stuff and
nine times out of ten we go Wow you did
it again it's awesome this is really
really good stuff sometimes we go hey
this is cool but what if we did it this
way or instead of going left we went
right it's sort of blue it was red and
we try to find out where we can find
some commonalities to find something
that maybe it's not hitting on the mark
the first time and just needs to just
maybe a little bit of iteration or
massaging but it's it's one of those
things where like I said three months
sounds like a lot of time I know you
guys say no it doesn't tell my when I
told Mike my wife and kids we have three
months to make this game they're like oh
yeah forever none of my design team
feels like that nobody feels like that
the art team doesn't feel like that
everybody works really hard we've been
we've been crunching pretty hard to get
infinite warfare as a whole done then of
course we spend the next part of the
year supporting the DLC and then title
updates and patches and new content and
all of that kind of yeah work is far
from over where we're always we're
always working on content and I'm kind
of sick in the head in a sense like I'll
go home and I'll have been at work for
you know 10 12 hour a day with the team
and then I'll go and sit on Twitter and
chat with the community man or going or
ogle you know go play game a game or two
with the community and you know just
kind of shoot you know shoot around kill
some zombies and have a good time for a
little bit burn off some steam is that
relaxing to you to play something that
you're also crunching on it is and and
part of it is that when I'm so how we're
playing right now this isn't how I play
at work when I'm playing at work I'm
counting bullets I'm doing things like
wait how come that that's
five shot this scripts that supposed to
take four something's not working here
so I'm looking at it from a development
standpoint when I'm playing it now I'm
going does this area feel fun it's right
well is this too tight oh wow this
actually I really like going to this
route I'm gonna start using this weapon
or oh I didn't I didn't think about
trying to hold down this area do you
look at it from a different perspective
and then also when you play with the
community you get to see a way that
people play that don't play like devs
right and so you get to you get to see
new experiences and also new strategies
and it helps me learn things that I just
playing with my design team I wouldn't
necessarily learn or experience those
things if I didn't if I didn't have
those opportunities so me personally I
think it's a big part of my development
philosophy is getting out there and
experiencing your shift content and
knowing what it feels like in your hand
so that you can go hey when that guy on
YouTube said that thing felt like this
you can go oh yeah I know because I felt
it myself and I know it feels like that
so yeah I know it sounds crazy but good
job it makes me feel better about the
products that we put out when we we pay
very close attention to what we're doing
yeah we do what we call retail checks
and it's something that has kind of been
burned into our DNA since we were before
Infinity Ward and never saw from earch
together but we would do retail checks
and look basically what that would mean
is we'd ship piece of content and
immediately the day it come out we'd all
get our retail kits pop our our copy of
the game in and then just immediately
sit down and play it and we would
literally sit down to play to go please
don't break please don't break please
don't break yeah and so you know it's
also one of those gut checks for
yourself to go yeah we pour our heart
and souls into this you know you don't
want to have spent you know the last 45
50 days working you know 15 16 hour days
only to press X and the game not work
right right so it's also just to make
sure that every all of our ducks are in
a row
moving along exactly how we need it and
then then I can actually go to sleep
arrest I guess
just talking about development and then
then launching it when you're done we
can talk about this is out today on ps4
yeah you didn't mention that that out
today post on ps4 can you say when it's
coming elsewhere it'll it'll be coming
in the near future for Xbox one and PC
players right now ps4 players they're
getting to the bread and butter of this
whole experience I hope those guys are
really enjoying it
but PC and Xbox guys don't worry we have
not forgotten about you content is
coming your way before you know it
but yeah tackle the reactive thing it's
out now it is a very very different take
on zombies in comparison to anything
that we've done thus far as I mentioned
in our conversation earlier it's a
daytime map we've got crog's that were
fighting which are these amphibious crab
frog looking things we've got a giant
massive 40 story boss that we're gonna
take on at some point we've got a brand
new wonder weapon we've got a brand new
card brand new fate and fortune cards we
have brand new challenges for this map
there's just so much content in this
thing we really really really cramped it
to the brim not to mention tons of
Easter eggs tons of things like these
recorders to find and I mentioned it a
bit earlier and I'm gonna give people a
quick sneak peek at where it we're to
look but that book right there get close
attention to that book people are gonna
want to know about that book man getting
all the expert hints so yeah with that
being said I mean this is great content
we've got a lot coming for you guys I
don't want to show too much cuz we want
people to dive in and experience it
themselves firsthand obviously but we
hope everybody's seen some really
awesome stuff today and the tack of the
radioactive thing is on their minds yeah
lots of great place to close of course
we did die because we were gonna die
Scroggs are rough but yeah so that was
attack the radio radioactive thing the
newest map for infinite warfare zombies
thank you so much for coming by and
showing it off and thank you all for
watching we'll see you next time